a new podcast is called sibling revelry
so tell us more about the podcast like
what happened and why did you want to do
it you know we we really
it kind of just came from
us saying like we should do a podcast
yeah it was like that simple
and and
and were you all close growing up like
is this what what yeah well no it i mean
the idea that
no no we weren't we weren't i mean we
were closed by proximity you know
obviously yeah like we are right i think
that's what makes the podcast nice
because they're we we do revere each
other now but back in the day we were
going through some stuff and that's
sisters and brothers
well what's interesting is that since
we've been interviewing so many siblings
we realized that a lot of times we're
sort of like i'm like why weren't you
like that when we were kids like they
are so nice and then i'm like why aren't
you like this now
i have an excuse i was eight
what's your excuse
how much therapy should be no but it's
really it's really it's really a special
show for us because it started as us
wanting to work together and do
something siblings was the obvious thing
it's an underexplored relationship i
think and really when siblings are
together more than when we are with our
parents you know i mean that's what all
we have yeah and we we lean on each
other and we fight and there's all kinds
of dynamics and we want to tell my kids
this because they're i was a child of
george they are too yeller as well but i
tell my kids this i'm i keep saying to
them i'm like quit fighting amongst each
other they're 22 months apart i'm like
you're each other's like buddy for life
like if you're gonna get mad get mad at
me yeah it's funny because these
relationships siblings and the whole
family dynamic they define who we are
you know and as we grow up you kind of
you're either looking to
sort of uh separate yourself from
whatever that dynamic is and try to sort
of pave your own way because you're fine
or you're trying to continue to nurture
those relationships and so when we talk
to all these different people
the the common denominator of all of it
is everyone wants to feel loved by their
sibling absolutely and you know yeah and
and and some people aren't really able
to get there they aren't really able to
have that like close connection based on
where they were raised what the divorce
situation was and how it affected each
child
like we had someone on estrangement yeah
on sibling estrangement which is really
an interesting yeah which something that
we know a lot about you know and with
her father but but um and then we had a
twin expert oh yeah that's right
can i tell you something what when you
sang that song on american idol oh sorry
i lost it i was pregnant i loved it
but
because
exactly you know it yeah yeah so no you
know what's interesting though that
dynamic is i i everything changed
whenever i became a mom because then i
realized the gravity of the situation
and that's where that song came from
because i was like you know i accepted a
lot of things you work through things
yeah and then when you come you're like
how could you leave your house i would
never leave yeah i know
but you know then you have to do that
and then you have to get to the po
the then you have to start looking at
that you know forgiveness and their life
and why they're like exactly and talk
about repairing like what does that mean
and is it possible is it not i mean it's
just you know we
sometimes it isn't sometimes it isn't
sometimes it is you know and then
sometimes you know it's really important
to repair because that's gonna you know
it's there it's available and it you
know that's different for each child
yeah even my sister my brother and i all
experienced the divorce of our family
very different
you know we found which we didn't even
realize was how many people tune in
and really feel like they're
able to share
and their stories with us and people be
more open with you than they are with
like people that are close to them yeah
like these are things we should be
talking about like that's one thing i
think that you know in today's day and
age like we need to sort of be looking
you know more inward and at the family
dynamic you know
um mental health in general yeah
oh yeah and these things really you know
even just talking about it and exploring
them and even you know having a sense of
humor about things that are really hard
that you know oliver and i can be
laughing and have a very dark sense of
humor about things yeah then at the same
time we cry at like the drop like we
can't even get into our email reads
episodes without balling i mean cause we
do we we listen our emails and stuff and
i i i'm a total mess yeah we're just
both hate you should have to take over
it's gotta be therapeutic as well though
connecting with all those people it is
it is you know i i think family we we
think family is everything and this is
coming from a family that is not perfect
we're a patchwork family family is and
and that's the thing that's also fun
because
we have
deeper conversations and it's funny when
you have the mic in front of your face
there's a there's a safety there for
some reason i don't know why but i'm
able to sort of express myself even
even better than with when they're when
we're not on yeah i'm like why did this
take you like
30 years to express this like on air
like on yeah but that's still not
getting anywhere
all i get is well i'm sorry you feel
that way
[Music]
you